I think there's a general impression
that the best science fiction writers
are American and British is that your
opinion well it's hard for me to say I
read science fiction only in English and
I my own surroundings my own circle of
friends of all the english-speaking
science fiction writers but I know for
instance that right now Stanislaw LEM
a polish science fiction writer is
considered one of the best in the world
and there are there are science fiction
writers in the Soviet Union that are
highly thought of and I suspect that in
time to come more and more there'll be a
diminution of the rank of the of the of
the English speaking domination of the
field more and more we will be aware of
non English science fiction
you